今天加一课。
第五课。
为什么加这一课呢？呃是因为前面的课讲完之后啊。
陆续收到一些反馈。
我觉得有几个朋友。
提的问题或者是表达的疑问还是比较有代表性的。有必要说一说，我们先回顾一下，咱们之前都学了点啥吧，好吧。
咱们之前的课程啊，其实就是教大家讲故事。
因为我说了。
故事是剧本的基础，是剧本的原材料呀。
嗯，你电影是讲故事的一种方式，电视剧也是讲故事的一种方式。所以编剧说白了他就是讲故事的人。
我们必须先得学会怎么讲故事。什么是故事？所以我们的课程前面讲过啊，什么是故事？什么是讲故事的人。
然后怎么讲故事？
故事的三大要素讲过吧。
三大要素又分成8个要素。
细分成8个要素。
我们回顾一下吧。好吧，这些关键点我们都得反复。
反复强调。
都要记住，好吧，三大要素是人物。
分。
吃饭。
欲望。
动作。
然后事件。
和。
这个世界分什么问题。
障碍。
也就是。
主力。
也有说叫沟壑。
然后结果。
然后。
主题。
正价值。
副驾值。
正负价值。
8个元素。
我们讲了故事这8个元素，然后告诉大家8个元素穿起来就是一个完整的故事。
按照这个顺序穿起来，就是一个完整的故事。然后后面我们又讲了一堂说这八个元素穿起来是一个完整的故事了，但有可能是一个平庸的故事。
在实战当中，我们怎么把它变成精彩的故事？
8个元素分别怎么增强烈度加强一下，记得吧。
也有这么一堂课。
把8个元素加强。
然后后来我们知道怎么写一个完整的故事，也怎么知道怎么样把它变成一个精彩的故事了。但是呢。
有时候还是无从下手。
没有灵感，没有办法。
我又给大家讲了5个常见的切入口。
对不对？
上节课又给大家讲了5个常见的切入口啊。
可以从哪些呢？
可以从身份切。
对吧。
可以从激励事件切。
可以从过激行为。
切入。
可以从。
悬念。
还可以从环境。
注意搞清楚区别啊，这5个点。
是从八元素中抽出来的，但是不是说这5个点构成一个故事，是这5个点。我认为在八元素中。
是可以作为你的突破口的。
对吧？
打蛇打7寸，这都是7寸。你搞，比如说你搞出一个很好的激励事件，哎，你这个故事就有起点了。
你就这个7788了，就基基本上差不多了，是这么个意思。
你这5个你只要能搞定一个。
你这个故事最起码可以开始动手了。
五个突报口。
明白吗？
我们之前的课程就讲了这些。
为什么要讲这些呢？教会你写故事。
先有故事，再有剧本。
这就是咱们之前讲过的课程。
啊，那么咱们来说一说。
我收到一些反馈收到一些反馈。
第一个反馈特别有代表性。我当时看到我的直接我就笑了。但我一下想起我年轻的时候，所以我觉得我我我很有必要呃在这里统意给给大家解答，我觉得肯定不止他一个人这么想。
嗯，他说什么呢？
他说老师，你不要教我们写故事了。
这些原理。
这些基础你直接告诉我们剧本的格式。
对吧剧本是什么样的格式，分多少个场，每场里面这个这个镜头怎么摆，演员怎么调度，怎么写，你告诉我们。
我一下想起我年轻的时候，也曾经这么。
狂过，这不叫狂啊，就是一般提出这样问题的同学。
我猜啊他首先他肯定是有天赋的，有一定天赋。
感觉得故事与我都在我心中了。你现在就是告诉我一个格式，我把我心中的故事往外输出就可以了。我卡上去，我现在唯一就不知道这个这个剧本分多少页那个分多少场格式是什么。我现在唯一不知道就就是这个所有的故事都在我心里了。
或或者在我的人生当中，在我身体里呢。
我我我就直接我就直接输出就可以了。你给我一个格式，给我一个模板。
就是所以他肯定是有一定天赋的。
还有一种情况呢，为什么有呃谁会这么想呢？就那种阅偏无数的人。
他觉得哎呀我好莱坞的好片子，对吧？百大影片什么五十大什么悬疑片，六十大爱情片，我了然于胸，看过的不止一遍，我都能写出影评。
我跟那些呃对吧？好莱坞名导演谈笑风生，在影片里谈笑风生。
很正常。
有这种想法很正常。我想起我年轻的时候，我什为什么说这个问题我一看就笑呢？
我刚入行的时候，写第一个剧本之前。
我就这么想法，反觉得自己既有天赋，然后又冷又有基础，阅篇无数呀。
既有天赋也有基础。然后我就想做编剧，我找了一个老编剧，老编剧呢请教一下人家跟人家说，我想做编剧。然后他说啊，那你到家里来吧。
指点你一下。
然后我就去了，我去了之后，发现这个老编剧啊精心准备。
他准备从理论到实践系统的跟我上一课，这么厚的一摞书放在那。
呵呵。
然后呢，我就在听他说了几句之后，我就我就说了。
今天有得赶时间啊。
你有没有写过的剧本？
你那种不要的剧本淘汰掉了也可以，就那种没有保密。
没有保密责任的那种剧本，十年前的都行。
你给我一本给我一级，对吧？我看看，我带回去研究一下。
然后他就很错愕，哎，这怎么会有这样的要求，然后呢就给了我一本。
给欧了一本，我就拿回去了，我怎么想的？
我就是跟这些同学想法差不多，就是故事与我都在心中已经胸有成竹了。你给我个条条框框，我就输出了。
我就是这么想的对吧？你一个。
我说句难听的，就我跟好莱坞。
我好莱坞电影，我看好莱坞电影的。
什么好莱坞电影我看不明白，什么里面的暗喻，里面的那个那个呃呃经典细节我都都能捕捉到。
你老编剧，你跟我上什么课呀，对不对？我开法拉利的，我开过法拉利，开过保时捷。你一个比亚迪的设计师，你跟我聊汽车。
当时就这么想的。
回去以后呢，发现。
哎呀，不是那么回事儿。
就你没写过呀。
你想的再多都没有用。
回去一写就发现写成流水账。
写成流水上，就那个同学问的说什么镜头怎么摆？
呃，演员怎么调度，你问出这个问题，我就知道你肯定不是这行的人，对吧？因为这个这是这不是剧本的范围，这是脚本的范围，这是拍摄脚本的才会写到镜头和演员调度这样的。
那是导演组的工作，不是剧本组的工作。
就说明你不是这行人，你也没有写过。
没有写过啊，就先写故事，听我的先写写看先写写看。
不要犯我当年的错误，觉得啊，我胸有成竹，你只要给我格式，我就能搞出剧本。后来发现自己记了一篇流水账。
后来我想明白了，我是开过法拉利。
我是开过保时捷，我看过很多牛逼的大片儿。
那你就有资格瞧不起比亚迪的发动机设计师吗？
没有资格。
他大小不计是个设计师。
对吧他能做出零件，做出汽车。
你只是。
看过。
你你只是个司机，你看过而已。
所以大家不要这么想，我呃不要着急，我的意思是。
先把故事，先把讲故事学会，再写学写剧本，咱们下一部分不就讲到写剧本嘛？不要着急，对吧？还有还当然还有一种情况，我我不不能说提这样问题的同学，他一定是那个呃呃就是我说的这种只会开车的司机。还有一种情况就是人家有可能写过小说。
有很多人有一定文学功底，写过东西的，他会说你你你只要把剧本格式告诉我就可以了。
我再给大家讲一个故事，说次不是我我一个朋友。
南派三叔写盗墓笔记的那个。
呃，那个那个作家。
他可以说在小说网，特别是就是网文这一块，小说这一块。
也算一个。
这个泰山北斗极的吧。
写的非常。
版税一年好几千万。
泰山被种。
当年他这个盗墓笔记刚开始要开发电影的时候，版权正好在我一个朋友手里。
然后呢，我们就一起开会呃，跟南派三叔。
一起开会说这个这个搞成电影啊，他写小说的呀，非常自信。他说那剧本我来啊，我这。
对吧1天一万字的这种产量写个剧本。
不就是。
三天四天的事情嘛。
但然他不是这么说的啊，但是他是这种感觉，他就说那剧本我来。
但是我们不放心啊。
你是作家写剧本，这这隔这行呢。
然后呢，我还特别小心，特别好心给他。
写了个纲。
就告诉他。
电影剧本一一般来说，先要解决人物出场的问题，再要解决激励事间的问题，再要解决什么问题。
列了一个结构纲给他。
然后他拿了这个缸回去以后，回杭州以后。
杳无音信，好几个月没动静，到最后也没写出来。
我的意思是什么呢？就是即便你是有文学基础，你只要没写过剧本。
你就先学学讲故事。
先学一学。
剧本讲故事的逻辑啊。
他是有自己的规律的。
很值得学，好吧。
我还有一个朋友的例子，我也可以给大家讲一下。
也是这种情况。
就是。
确实也有天赋，很有天赋来找我说。
我要写剧本。
你这个。
你你帮我看看，对吧？我说没问题啊。
这哥们儿东北的。
平时说话特别逗，可以逗的所有人前仰后合。他一说话大家都爱听，属于那种天赋。哎，我说过有有这种人是吧？有天赋，这而且这种天有这种天赋的人，东北偏多。
东北偏多。
一套一套的科，然后呢，这哥们儿就就会去写写写还产量还挺快，这产量挺高，写挺快。回他拿来，我一看，我操七八页啪。
看着看着就不对，他这个他这个剧本啊有一个规律。
连续七八页全是甲说了什么，乙说了什么，甲又说了什么，乙又说了什么。
通篇全是这种，当然也换场景啊，甲和乙开始在家里沙发上甲说什么，乙说什么，甲说什么乙说什么，甲说什么乙说什么，然后第二场在车上，甲开车，乙在副驾驶，甲说什么，乙说什么，甲说什么，乙说什么第三场在饭店，两个人吃饭，甲说什么，乙说什么，甲说什么，乙说什么，然后我跟他说，哥们。
恕我直言啊，好看是挺好看的，但这不是剧本。
这是相声啊，对不对？你给他们换场干嘛？他们不用换场，在家里去这三场戏在家里都能办了，那没有必要换场。
所以就这意思啊，就是不管你是天赋异禀。
还是阅偏无数，对吧？开过法拉利。
还是说你呃你的工作与创作与写作有关系。
我都可以告诉你。
还是先学一学剧本写故事的逻辑。
你如果觉得不用学，那你就先写一个故事嘛。
对吧？
咱们正好也说到这儿了，咱们第一第一部分。
故事这里。
刚要在这儿。
如果认真听了的同学，现在基本上是应该是有创作冲动的。
5个突破口选一个。
把八要素写完整。
每个人写一篇。
1000到2000字。
左右吧，1500字左右的。
一个故事包含完整八要素的故事。
看这个视频，大家可以关注我们的公众号，好吧，呃，到时候我把这个公众号字幕打在下面。
大家关注这个公众号，里面有我们的交流的群。
可以把作业交给我。
写的这个故事纲交给我，我会跟你一对一沟通，每一篇怎么怎么改。
然后第二部分怎么写剧本的时候，怎么把故事改成剧本的时候，你就有一个自己的故事了，有一个自己的依据了。
好吧。
这是解答这个同学的疑问，就是什么时候写剧文啊，他就是着急了，你知道吗？这不是坏事，他着急。
恨不得就是我发一个那个剧本格式给大家是吧？我可以发给大家，我可以发给大家好莱坞原版的剧本，你去看一看他们的格式。
呃那个网上你也估计也搜得到，没有用，对你写故事来讲没有用，好吧，而且我这么说吧。
你如果真的故事能写好。
你只是不会格式而已。
我免费给你写，把你的好故事改成剧本。
因为好故事才是。
才是最难得的。
才是最珍贵的。
格式不重要。
不会因为说哇一个特别好的故事，因为格式写错了，大家就不喜欢了，不可能的，我给你改免费，好吧。
然后第二个问题。
是另外一个朋友提出来一个问题。
写的非常好，我觉得有必要今天来回答一下。
这个问题呢其实我是有准备的，我准备在第四部分查漏补缺讲点。
各种没有讲到的问题的时候，讲这个来着。
但是我没想到这么有呃敏锐的同学。
那肯定也是很有天赋的人啊。
他提出来了。
提出这个问题。
我觉得有必要。
提前回答一下什么问题呢？他说你反复强调一个剧本的主题。
要是正能量。
说什么正义战胜邪恶，而且反复强调一定要这样。
然后这个同学说我不同意。
我不同意，他说。
现实生活中有邪恶战胜正义的时候呀。
而且已经拍出来的片子很好的片子也有也有。
邪恶他就赢了呀。
你为什么说一定要正义战胜邪恶呢？你怎么就那么。
就就嫌你那么正义呢。
你说的。
不对。
这个同学提出了呃这个问题。
提的非常好提的非常好。因为我本来打算后面有一节课专门的来讲这个问题。我没想到这么快提出来。
很敏锐。
那我们就讲一下。
也给大家都解答一下这个问题，好吧，而且这这这解答这个问题，我就作为这一课的主题了，这一课就叫。
剧本的正义。
先给大家很简单的回答一下这个问题。
他说，你凭什么说正义一定战胜邪恶？
难道就没有邪恶战胜正义的那种事儿吗？
当然有。
但是你不要忘了。
我说的是什么正义战争邪恶？
我说的是主题。
正义战胜邪恶。
我在说正能量的时候，我说主题一定要是正能量。
主题的正义战胜主题的邪恶，主题的正价值战胜主题的附加值。你说的邪恶战胜了正义，比如说写一个战争片，对吧？
那么有些战争他就是邪恶一方战胜了呀。
那是结果。
那是结果懂吗？
结果有可能是不尽如人意的。
邪恶赢了。
但是你作为一个剧本，一个故事，你的主题是正义的。
很难理解吗？
剧本的争义。
剧本的正义就是要区分。
主题的正义和结果的正义。
咱们讲的那个呀。
那个想要殉职的那个警察。
那个故事记得吗？那是咱们这节课属于咱们这节课的故事呀，咱们创造的故事呀，那个天天想殉职的警察，它的主题是什么来着？
活着更好，活着比死了好，活着可以保护更多的女儿。
保护更多的人。
这不就是主题吗？这个主题是不是正能量？
当然是正能量呀，活着更好呀。
但是说结果的时候，我不是跟大家说吗？结果不重要，你随便选一个，他抓住了凶手，然后他自己呢勇敢的活下去，保护守护更多的人。咦，这是一种结局。还有抓住的凶手，但是他跟凶手同归于尽，他死了。然后呢，还有呢他根本没抓住凶手。
都可以。
对吧他没抓出凶手都可以啊，但是他发生了蜕变。
也就是说，结果他可以是邪恶赢了。
结果可以是邪恶赢了。
但是主题活着更好，保护更多的人主题剧本的正义得到了伸张，明白这个意思吗？
所以我们说我们所谓的。
正义是指剧本的正义。
不是实际的争议。
明白这个道理了吗？
我给大家讲一个最简单的例子。
嗯。
韩国有一部电影叫杀人回忆。
非常好的电影。
杀人回忆是这样啊，杀人回忆是。
零几年的吧，到现在得有20年了。
11189年。
快20年的一个电影。
杀人回忆被称为韩国影史。
排名第一的电影。
而且争议比较小。
就大家普遍都这么认为。
当然现在韩国有有寄生虫了，得了很多奥斯。哎呃。
杀人回忆就是寄生城的导演。
宋俊浩拍的同一个导演。
细节控那个导演。
很很很那个导演非常的细节控，会做很多细节在一个电影里，杀人回忆也是他拍的呀，而且也是宋康浩主演的寄生虫里面那个男一宋康浩演的杀人回忆的男一。
如果说现在它不是韩国影史第一，韩国影史第一变寄生虫的话，那也还是同一同一拨人，就说明这个电影之好。
韩国的电影是非常强的。
韩国影史第一的电影，那基本上也。
也是亚洲。
比不上霸王别姬的话，也至少可以。
呃相提并论。
就是这么好的一个电影。
非常好非常好，没有看过的，大家一定要去看一下。好吧，听完这堂课一定要看一下。
杀人回忆这个电影就是呀。
两个警察，其中一个是宋康，两个警察。
80年代。
一个小镇上发生了连环奸杀案。
手段非常残忍，奸杀女性。
这两个警察。
一个是这个小镇上的警察，本地的，一个是首尔过来的见多识广的这种警刑警。
两个警察。
抓这个。
连环奸杀案的这个。
坏蛋。
到最后没抓到。
而且他们有一个他们已经95%确定的嫌疑犯。
就在他们手眼前，就在他们手中。
我们迫切想要将他绳之于法。
最后都没有没有成功，还是给他。
呃放掉了。
看起来不就是邪恶赢了吗？
正义没有得到伸张呀。
没有抓到坏人呀。
没有抓到坏人。
那你说这个片子我们怎么理解？
是不是我符符合我说的主题，一定要一定要正能量，一定要正义呢？那这个片子是不是就是负能量呢？
详细说一下，好吧。